[Music]
good afternoon everyone
how are you I'm Laurie lamenting
Guardium with Silicon Valley Bank and
it's really a pleasure to be here today
for those of you that are not here to
learn about angel investing now would be
the time to leave this is this panel is
on angel investing those of you that are
excited to put to learn about angel
investing when it takes as a future
entrepreneurs to get funded by angel
investors welcome so a little bit about
me at SBB I manage the bank's
relationships with angels universities
and incubators so I immersed myself in
the angel world for the past twelve to
eighteen months and it's really really
exciting to be here to talk with our
panel here we have a really unique and
diverse mix here we've got two very very
successful entrepreneurs that have
raised significant amount significant
amounts of capital both from angels as
well as from institutional investors we
have a mix as far as one as a serial
entrepreneur and the other is a
first-time entrepreneur so you're going
to hear a unique perspective in terms of
their experiences in raising capital and
what it's been like we also have the
great pleasure of having two really
wonderful angel investors who have been
at this for quite a long time so we have
Bob zip and in Eden sanket who both have
a fund that they invest through and to
have seen a lot of deals over the years
so I'm actually I'm going to let our
panelists rather than read their BIOS
I'm going to let our panelists introduce
themselves and maybe talk for for Bob
and I didn't talk a little bit about how
you got into angel investing and for our
new and Todd maybe talk a little bit
about your companies and your your
fundraising process so you okay I'm
gonna mean sponsor I'm
founder and managing general partner of
a fund called amicus Capital in San
Francisco I founded amicus in 1998
initially it was a twenty five million
dollar fund its structure doesn't have a
evergreen so I've continued to invest
out of proceeds and I've invested close
to 40 million today I focus on very
early-stage companies typically to
people to entrepreneurs and a business
plan sort of what I say pre-product
pre-revenue you know to immediately post
conception usually I got into investing
as a lawyer I vote for the ten years
before I started amicus I was a lawyer
with Brubeck flagrant Harrison and with
venture law group here in the Silicon
Valley representing tech companies and
in that process came to know many angel
investors and institutional VCS was
interested in being on the other side of
the table and took took the opportunity
when it arose sure
my name is Anu Shukla I'm a serial
entrepreneur I founded three companies
and I've used both angel funding and VC
funding actually all three companies
were vc-backed and also had some angel
money to get us off the ground I have on
occasion angel invested myself so you
know I think I was we were discussing
this panel before and I thought it was
particularly interesting that the times
have kind of changed in terms of how you
can get to revenue a lot faster and it
changes the flavor of how anybody should
view funding angel VC or otherwise my
name is Eden Sanket I've been making
angel investments for the last four
years through my entity felices ventures
I was an early Googler I was there from
99205 I started as the first product
manager and was responsible for the
international expansion and when I
left I kind of took advantage of this
wave of costs going dramatically down to
start a company mostly in the consumer
internet and mobile sector and in the
four years I made over 50 investments
and have 11 exits to date and even
though I invest in a smaller financial
scale compared to Bob what I try to do
is really help the entrepreneurs with
getting the best investors helping them
form syndicates and then really helping
them ad major turning points in their
companies and I also happen to be to
happen to know Todd as a friend and also
an investor in his company so it's it's
a very interesting perspective today to
be on the panel my name is Todd sat
Revati I actually attended Stanford
Business School graduated in 2003 and in
August of 2006 I raised money for a
company called bright roll which I
co-founded with an engineer who I knew
from my prior company since that point
we've raised three rounds $1,000,000
angel round and then two subsequent
institutional rounds so I've sort of
learned a lot about the fundraising
process both as a first-time
entrepreneur and as going through both
angel and institutional fundraising
processes so look forward to the
dialogue what I hope to do in the next
hour and an hour and 15 minutes or so is
really help demystify the fundraising
process
give you some insights on what angels
look for when they're looking for deals
and also just some strategies around how
you might approach fundraising from
angels and some of the differences and
nuances between raising angel funding
and institutional funding so I'm going
to say plenty of time for Q&A but we're
gonna start our kind of a general
dialogue right now and you know if you
have questions feel free to to chime in
as we go along so it's so Todd to kick
it over to you first so I read and once
I read somewhere that when you read when
you raise your first round of funding
that you had nine angel investors lined
up for that so can you maybe talk a
little bit about how you got to nine and
what it was like corralling nine angels
I mean we often hear that ain't hurting
angels like
herding cats though I'd imagine that was
kind of a overwhelming process yeah I
was challenging I think that you know at
that time we were as a company myself
and my co-founder we really made the
decision that we wanted to have angel
investors and not institutional
investors a lot of that was driven by
you know we were extremely early stage
we still wanted to have a lot of
flexibility around making decisions we
didn't want to sort of have a huge
overhang of capital in the company and
we were still just iterating really
quickly and from our diligence with
other companies we had heard that that
sort of that was the right path and so
we pursued it so we met in the process
probably about 50 investors through that
process most of the leads that we talked
to during the process came from you know
a very small set of personal
relationships and then asking you know
every investor we talked to to give us
two or three other names of people that
you know they thought highly of and it
really is very much an iterative process
through that group but we talked about
on the call earlier but the most
important thing for us during that
process is to find somebody who's
willing to lead the round and the person
who's willing to lead the round really
ended up corralling the group and sort
of driving the group driving the process
driving the timing and so once we found
that it did make the process a lot
easier but still it was definitely
hurting cats for the for the beginning
process and really just trying to get
interest and a new how about you maybe
talk a little bit so for three companies
you've been out there and I understand
that you've intentionally raised from
angels so maybe we've talked a little
bit about that
oh yes to me it was I always when I
started these companies I always thought
they were targets for venture money the
first company I did was a company called
rubric for which I raised about thirteen
point six million dollars from venture
capitalists and initially the our angels
were my co-founders you know relatives
and my relatives and myself so what we
wanted to do was really take a you know
quarter of a million or a half million
dollars and prove our concept so we
could get a higher valuation in series a
and that I thought was the the sum total
of the reason to raise angel mind is a
need some seed money whether it's coming
from me our a group of people interested
people we didn't really think about the
value they could add it was just these
people are going to put money in without
any questions without even a meeting
they're just gonna send a check okay and
they're never going to talk to us again
and what we're gonna do with this money
is we're gonna you know go talk to
prospective customers maybe build a
prototype and then spend the time to pay
for the office and then go talk to
venture capitalists so my goal was
always to get to VC because in the first
company was building an enterprise
software company it was rumored that you
needed you know 50 million dollars to
really build an enterprise software
company
you know we managed to have an exit
after raising thirteen point six million
dollars for about three hundred sixty
six million so everybody was happy
including our Angels who made a ton of
money and we always did this as a
convertible because it was a small
amount so they gotten at the series
evaluation with a little warrants and
stuff for the second company same I was
building an enterprise software company
which evolved into a SAS company again
it takes a lot of money to build those
and so I was in a position to put more
money as an angel myself but also again
friends and family co-founders relatives
that sort of thing generally the first
group that had invested it the first
company came along and then I did the
third company which is called alpha pal
media and over here I also took a little
bit of angel but I found that this is
you know web 2.0 I could actually get
the product built pretty quickly without
too much angel money even and again my
target was just to get to that you know
VC round at the highest valuation
possible so I raised you know four point
six million dollars in my series a after
putting in you know quarter of a million
of angel from various same friends and
family and never thinking that the angel
would add any value except send the
check and don't bother me and it turns
out that alpha pal you know became
profitable in three months and started
to hit triple digits revenue we never
touched that funding and so when I look
back in it I said you know we should
have raised any money at all or we
should have really gone to some angels
who could
are you and maybe raised a million to
make us feel good and attract talent and
this wasn't a VC deal at all you know
not if you can hit profitability in
three months maybe you go for venture
then and then you get a much higher
valuation so I'm really rethinking my
whole just take some non-obtrusive
angels and then go straight for VC
strategy I'm completely rethinking it
for venture number four it's good to be
thinking of venture number four as well
so in bobbin and I'd and I know that
you're both pretty hands-on so maybe we
can talk a little bit about the
difference between a value-added
investor and a non value-added investor
so in your opinion how how involved are
you
you're pretty involved with your
companies what are some of the things
that you're doing for your companies as
you're investing so let me take a first
shot at it because my answer is gonna be
non-traditional let me recall for I am
NOT hands-on I am high-value at or at
least that's my goal and let me also
clarify what that means so a lot of
people ask me as an angel well how much
time do you spend with your companies
and as you well know this is not about
quantity it's about quality I feel that
there are four or five major milestones
in the company's history and to the
extent that I can help in those and not
really mix you know cause any trouble
with the founder and always be there
when the founder needs me
that's the highest value I can add the
first milestone is fundraising so the
most important thing I can do for the
founder is like Todd said getting that
lead in getting the right investor mix
is really important and a lot of time
because the founders are also running
the company and growing the company they
don't have time to really understand the
investor universe and figure out what is
the best match for them so that's one
area I can help the second one is hiring
and critical decisions in the company
and when I started I've seen how some of
these things could be greatly done at
Google and I think that was a very
valuable experience I also went to
business school but I feel a lot of the
significant things I learned at Google
how they did things out of the box in
terms of other value add or miles high
miles important milestones in a
company's history then there are like
important hiring decisions or sales
decisions so that's where I try to come
in
make connections and the very last one
is when actually a liquidity event
happens I don't think we see as many
IPOs today but the acquisitions are
pretty common and that's a very very
tough process and being able to get
exposure for my companies increasing
their potential likelihood I can spend
one hour on a phone call actually make
an exit happen or double the company's
value it's Val worth more than a
thousand dollars I can spend with the
founder and also I think there is value
and not calling the founder every week
what have you done for me lately you
know I mean kind of leave the guy or in
a woman too in peace like they can run
their company but like be there for the
important things so I think this is one
of the important things there's always
this talk of like value-add VC value-add
angel I am very pragmatic about that I
mean it's all about the real value can
create for the founder it could be one
call it could be a connection but being
able to follow through that and execute
that is very important so would you ever
invest in a company that you felt you
couldn't add value or that really was
looking for a passive investor that I
would not because the other thing I was
gonna say I mean I don't want to get too
far carried away from the conversation
but you know you have to understand that
venture capital is not about risk
business is about risk reduction
business so we're looking for great
opportunities huge traction huge growth
and how we can reduce that risk so we
can make that outcome as likely as
possible so if I can add any value that
I'm dumb money and there's a lot of
capital out there so there is no sense
for me to get involved because basically
the very first thing I'm trying to do is
can I help this company in any way to
reduce the risk and increase the value
of the investment and create a win-win
situation
how about you bad I agree totally I'm in
my experience and I've invested in 50
companies too although over a much
longer time horizon there's an inverse
relationship between the level of
investor involvement and likelihood of
success the best companies have very
strong entrepreneurs with their own
minds we're very clear about where the
company is going and happy investors who
show up at board meetings and
you know enjoy the results high fives
all around
you know one of the first companies that
I invested in was subsequently invested
in by a venture investor who is no
longer in the business and you'll you'll
understand why when I tell you this
anecdote for the first 18 months of this
person's management of the investment
he had the CEO of the company call him
every day every day at 4:00 p.m. the CEO
would call explain what he had done that
day and explain what he planned to do
the next day and amazingly to the CEOs
credit the founder CEOs credit you know
the company was a success but he hated
every minute of it and a guy had you
know although he perceived himself to be
highly involved in highly value add he
was actually a value you know limit or
value detractor so you know I I agree
completely with with iDEN you want to
find investors who are who have
experience who are there to provide
helpful advice and counsel when you need
it and who are not stepping on your toes
when you don't need it so shifting gears
a little bit
I'm I'd like to talk a little bit about
the process and what it takes to
actually for as investors what it takes
for you to invest and as entrepreneurs
what it takes to get to a term sheet so
in the past 12 months
I didn't Bob how many deals have you
invested in and how many deals have you
seen relative to that so what you know
get us give us give me the books here
and a sense of what your deal flow is
absolutely so I invested over a dozen
deals in 2009 and that was a very tough
year and I'm probably right now I mean
it's hard to remember exactly how many
deals that I've seen but incoming leads
is probably around 10 to 12 a day and I
mean I have to be honest with you is
impossible to keep track of all of this
so it's really exciting and I have to
pick and choose which are the best
potential options so I can really help
them in terms of investment process
again I think you know the most
important thing here is every six to 12
months like Todd's uh let's just take a
deal so when I spoke to Todd he had some
critical elements of what
looking for so number one right at that
time video was exploding and I'm like
okay so I missed that wave it's too late
to invest in video because it's already
exploiting what's the next big thing
video monetization so that was one of
the five areas I was looking into and
that's exactly what Todd was targeting
the second thing is he was referred to
me by somebody that I really trust who's
an entrepreneur himself and is a very
good friend so I could you know I
already knew Todd but then I had
somebody that could really watch for him
so that's another really important thing
and then finally the thing that really
what it boils down to is you know you're
looking basically when you're meeting
the entrepreneurs and investors you want
to have confidence that whatever they're
saying they're gonna deliver during an
exciting business that's gonna grow fast
they have kind of figured out what they
need to do they have a good plan and
they're gonna create what I call an
unfair advantage and they have the best
chance to do so so when I looked at
Todd's track record I'm like great like
he's already worked at a great company
you know and everything that he told me
he had a strong grasp of the business
and more importantly he knew what his
differentiation was gonna be it wasn't
just a PowerPoint of or everybody's like
oh this is a billion dollar market you
know we gotta go and here's the
competitive matrix all of that what I
really want to hear is how you're gonna
Excel and make a difference with your
idea and how likely are you to do that
and just to kind of extent in the
previous point in the beginning it's not
like you have all the chips you want
your right is for you and your
co-founder maybe one or two other people
you have to look at your investors and
advisors as your extended team whatever
is the strengths you don't have whatever
is the domain expertise you don't have
that's basically an important function
of your investors and advisors being
able to get that mixed ride is one of
the most important thing you have the
best team even if you don't have the
best idea you have much higher chances
to win my finals a little bit smaller
than the Knighton's I probably looked it
looked actively at 200 deals last year
invested in five
and I looked actively I mean at least
had a meeting face to face and and
thought about it now I agree with iDEN
that that it's you know it's it's a
challenge to
be able to provide good feedback to
every entrepreneur who wants to meet
with you and that's that's probably my
biggest issue and my biggest regret you
know I wish I could provide more to all
the entrepreneurs out there who are
looking for funding and looking for
feedback so how does somebody grab your
attention though is that making that
personal connection to to you is there
you know if I'm an entrepreneur and I
want to I'm gonna get your attention
it's coming in through a trusted source
it is the way to optimize success come
in through a lawyer and entre you know
who is well-connected in the community
an entrepreneur who's well-known in the
community or someone in my network
another investor those are typically the
three best ways I agree with Bob and I'm
gonna try to expand and hopefully I can
put this into a ground work for you so
all you're trying to do when you're
trying to meet investors is create a
positive bias so let me explain what I
say most of the entrepreneurs I'm
meeting all you have to do is ten
percent more homework do your homework
in terms of who you're meeting what they
invested in the past have they said
anything in the press in terms of areas
that they're looking at and anything in
their background indicates that they're
gonna be interested in your idea so
people just kind of like launch into
their presentation they're excited about
their company but they don't even think
first of all they didn't read the body
language does this person even care
about the idea or even meeting me is
there a good chemistry I mean you have
all the sources now Google LinkedIn
Facebook I mean you can get so much
information in very short time about the
person find out if they have a positive
bias if they're a biker you're a biker
that's a positive bias if they worked in
health care you're trying to do a health
care startup that's a positive bias if
they invested in you know five video
related companies and they are
knowledgeable at advertising and you're
trying to do advertising that's a
positive bias what I'm trying to say is
if you try to talk to an investor that
looks great on paper but has no
connection to your idea you're not going
to get the connection and you're going
to be frustrated because you're gonna
keep having meetings and you're like why
is this person not relate to my idea
it's because they don't care right like
how do you make them care about the idea
how do you make them care about talking
to you and that's one of the most
important things you need to get across
so when somebody says get some more
attraction what if an entrepreneur hears
that
something that they should hear which is
they interpret that as really get some
more traction or is that a polite
brush-off because I think that's an
important entrepreneurs hear that quite
frequently well be also hear is
intriguing or fine delete you know yeah
I think get some more traction is
probably ninety nine percent of the time
that's a polite way of saying no
honestly or a polite way of just kicking
the can down the road and and trying to
stay connected with the entrepreneur in
case something good happens in the
future and intriguing means no unless
kleiner drops your term sheet in which
case I'm a little I think as a
first-time entrepreneur you know a
little bit of traction was extremely
important in my process so you know if I
were raising angel money today
I think off of you know reputation
relationships that have a lot more
success than I would have at then I did
at the time that I started and so when I
started the company I started it while I
was working at another startup you know
his nights and weekends and we worked on
it for six months till we had a you know
proto working prototype we had a couple
customers and then you know I left that
company and I spent three months
building the product before I went to
raise angel money because I felt that
you know at that time with my reputation
I wasn't gonna be able to raise angel
money without traction and so maybe the
feedback would have been get some
traction maybe that was good feedback so
I think that that you know I think that
those sort of the earlier you are in
your career and if it's your first time
entrepreneur traction of any kind is is
a great indicator and something that you
should focus on not just an idea a deck
so this traction and then days I just
filed the s-1 for the IPO some ways you
know you have to qualify for traction
really is and how many angels did you
approach before you got funding in your
first company I actually didn't approach
any of them they approached me because
remember they were part of a close-knit
group
you know so it's basically people that
were involved with a company even I can
inch a founding engineer would say well
you know my dad wants to put in a
hundred K anything so we're like okay
maybe he will take it so how long how
long is the process how long does it
take for you guys to come to a decision
is it you know you know in the first you
had me at hello anywhere from 48 hours
to multiple weeks partly it's it's so
again I mean I think everything kind of
boils down to the different risk
involved with making the startup
successful so there is funding risk so
let's say that you already have a lead
and you have some of the rounds spoken
for that it that decreases then you have
team risk so how comprehensive is it is
the team is it just one founder is it
two founders with two really good people
with some great advisors attached right
so it kind of comes down to the traction
problem if somebody's asking for
traction
basically the translation of all these
different things intriguing traction
whatever are two things number one there
are not enough data points for me to be
to have conviction and number two it
could also be you know what I'm not
really a capable person to have to be
convicted at early stage so I'm gonna
make the investment as late as possible
to reduce all the risk and that's I
think the black art of being a good
investor how early can you make that
decision and can still be right or have
good chances of being right but you know
basically what I'm trying to tell you
there are some times when you know the
deal is so hot that supply and demand
it's an incredible founder great idea no
no brainer and you as an investor you
want to be involved with that kind of an
entrepreneur and deal you know assuming
that there's a good match and sometimes
it's it's a tough process I mean there
have been times when I'm the first
investor that spoke to a founder and we
literally called every single investor
got turned around together and it took
longer but you know the outcome was
still the same it's supposed to become
getting it and again it's very important
when you're actually going through the
process yourself I mean Todd said he
spoke to 50 investors and got to nine so
it all comes down to like checking off
every risk factor and really asking
yourself have you really covered all the
important risk and and the investors
mind have you convinced them that you
have the best chance of winning against
the odds and do you have the right
unfair advantages to beat those odds
very good so what about valuation I mean
how do you value you know Bob I think
about you it's a concept at the
PowerPoint you know you've got a team
here that's ready to go is it you throw
a dart or generally the deals are valued
in two ways they're either valued as a
function of the venture around a
subsequent venture round and so
structure is a convertible note with
some you know warrants or a discount or
something so that the the whole
valuation question is sort of moved down
down to the the the next fundamental
event or if the deal is priced you know
generally it's priced within a valuation
range that assumes that they'll be a
reasonable markup on a subsequent
venture investment and that may that
sort of moves target moves up and down
and you know depending on the market and
the time and the environment and so
forth but but it's generally within
within a range so I think the simplest
way to look at it this is the question
that gets most asked how do you value a
company so it's very simple as supply
and demand in every other place in the
world for any price it's how much supply
you have and how much demand you have if
you have a lot of supply you have no
demand the price is going to be low so
the most important thing for you is not
to take that personally your job is to
increase the demand right so when you're
looking at the valuations I mean it's
ridiculous but for all the
sophistication we have at business
school in science we learn really you
don't really have any data points to go
by so everything else being equals
somebody who has more conviction and
positive bias towards your idea it's
probably going to be more receptive to
paying a higher price to be involved in
your company but again the most
important function is demand and then
basically for the investors to have
enough of a stake to compensate for the
early risks they're taking I mean it's a
fine balance right as an in as an
entrepreneur you don't want to give up
too much of your company but you also
have to be smart in the sense that if
you get the right people in the company
gets really big you might be giving a
little more of your company but then the
overall pie is bigger having an 80% of a
company that is not valued at anything
is not a good thing either so have a
reasonable balance and I think it's
really important to incentivize and
motivate your investors for the right
investors right so don't always get
stuck at this all I need to have the
perfect terms no I think
it is a balance of terms who the
investors are and how much value you
feel they're gonna bring on the table
and are they gonna be able to plug in
any of the holes that you have in your
team or in your company from the
entrepreneurs perspective do you guys
have a different view yeah I would just
add that you know during my process you
know I was really focused on basically
two things one was completing it
successfully I raising the money and the
second thing was having the process be
as short as possible because you know we
were a small team with limited resources
and we really just didn't want to be
distracted and so when I talked to lots
of different server entreprise that had
been through the process it seemed to me
that as a first-time entrepreneur the
fastest route was to pick a valuation
that was within the bounds of being fair
and doing a closed round not doing a
convertible because it was just easier
for people to understand they can make
the decision faster and they didn't have
to worry about you know the terms around
the convertible and so I basically just
picked a valuation that was comparable
to other deals that had gotten done and
said it's a Series A and and that proved
to be successful of course there's some
you know maybe we gave up some margin we
could have made more by having it
convert at the later round but the
reality was I got the money and it was
fast and that was the most important to
us I'm in the same boat there because I
just talked to comparable companies and
looked at what their Series A was done
at and for the angel how much discount
was I I was willing to do and work
backwards from there but I have to point
out that one of the things that we
didn't consider in the angel round we
considered the fact that we could get
this money and get going and there was
no overhead associated with raising the
money which was you know probably very
convenient but I think we missed an
opportunity at all three companies that
I did although all of them are
successful that was you know getting the
right angel involved could have you know
helped us in many many other ways and we
always thought once we get VC funding
we'll go get an advisory board and
before them in place and we'll pay them
give them stock to help us but I think
that we never gave enough importance to
getting the right angel involved early
in the car
and that's something if I had to do it
over I would I would rethink that
company number four number four is on as
we already aping up to a nice company so
far so you know one one thing I'd love
to talk about since we're on the subject
is how does an entrepreneur come up with
the right amount to raise and the first
round is it is it it doesn't really come
down to supply and demand what angels
are willing to invest in it or you know
is there kind of a set rule and that's a
really good question because I have to
say that everything that I'm saying on
this panel are limited to consumer
Internet and mobile companies so it's an
important distinction right and the
reason for that is a that's where I have
the experience and B that's where I've
seen is the higher highest chances of
growing a company fast that doesn't mean
that you can't have a very successful
company in CPG or in semiconductor or
any other areas there are a lot more
friction points getting things right and
getting through those hurdles is tougher
it's gonna require more capital so
that's where I focus where I focus but I
think the lessons are still applicable
to other areas as well and then when I
thought talked about supply and demand I
actually talked about the price in terms
of how much capital to raise is again I
think it's a surfing analogy right so
you're riding at the edge of that wave
you don't want to raise too much capital
where you get to locks you also don't
want to raise too little capsules that
you run out of money or you have to go
raise money a little bit too soon the
whole point here is that not getting too
carried away from the real value of the
company of course as an entrepreneur and
CEO you think very highly of yourself
and the company and you should and you
shouldn't have a healthy dose of an ego
but you should also be realistic in
terms of you know not not not that
valuation to get carried away too much
because you're gonna have to build the
company to that level so everything else
being equal raising just enough money to
get you to that next step and as Anna
said and I think Todd implied you know
the important traction points where as
obvious the company's growing fast is
obvious you're checking all the check
marks and you have a leadership position
that's gonna get you a higher valuation
and don't raise capital unless you need
to right I mean I heard an example that
Microsoft raised a total of a million
eBay raised five million Google raised
25 million and you know that was
probably for good reason but a lot of
these companies probably raise a lot
less than you expected for the size
the companies they are now so just
remember that and I know this is easier
said and done especially if you're in
semiconductor CPG or life sciences but
again the goal is like if you're in life
sciences you know try to find somebody
who knows the area who can help you with
the FDA process or you have a billion
idea and somebody that can help you
avoid costly mistakes and avoid getting
into some of those friction points think
of how much money we would need I think
it was all about having the money to
reach a milestone the next milestone so
whether it was shipping the product or
first to revenue I think a lot of people
we've talked a little bit about traction
that you know when you go to VCS or
angels and say well you need a little
bit more traction before I can't really
believe in it and what that really means
I still have to say that the first round
of the series a that you raise is the
easiest round okay
the bar really goes up significantly
from there because you have to explain
what you did with that formula n and
where you're at right now and now there
are other people there that need a
certain type of exit and you're trying
to raise the value so in some ways it's
an easiest ground but it's also
important to take as iden said the right
amount of money to get you to that next
important milestone because the bar is
higher when you get there so it's called
raising on hope versus raising on
reality right when you're raising your
Sirius C you're now being compared
because you have real revenue so you're
gonna be you know judged on almost
public market multiples or some stricter
financial criteria versus early on you
know you're kind of mostly raising money
on hope in terms of who you are what a
great idea you have and how convicted
people are that you're going to be able
to execute to grow this company the
protocol response that I give to
entrepreneurs to that question is you
know think think about the the
PowerPoint deck that you're gonna
present to the to the institutional
first institutional VC that you mean and
what would you like to have in there
what would you like to have in there in
terms of you know progress that you've
made with with the the angel capital
that you've raised plan - how long will
it take you to achieve those milestones
you add three to six months at three
months worth worth of run rate
and and that should be the target raised
amount usually that works out to
somewhere between 12 and 18 months in my
experience Anton I think you you
mentioned something earlier about
finding entrepreneurs that have braised
angel funds the importance of that in
terms of shadowing them huh how maybe
you could talk a little bit about that
and how that helped you with your around
yeah so one of the you know I when I
look back at my angel fundraising
process the the sort of key person and
the key sort of element in that process
was a friend of mine who had literally
just went through the angel investing a
certain age fundraising process himself
and you know as GSB students or
connected a stammerer there's lots of
people that are alumni that have went
through this same process probably in a
similar industry in the last you know
sort of 12 to 24 months and so they're
to have a shorthand for so many of the
decisions made my life so much easier so
I said you know how much do I need to
raise I did all my calculations trying
to figure it out and I had a benchmark
well he raised the million so and all
things being able look like I was about
same number so that seems about right so
what was his valuation he picked about
you I was very close to his valuation
and you know who I went to talked to
were similar to he went to talk to you
so in a lot of ways having a shorthand
for something that has zero experience
and made the process you know enormous
ly more efficient for me and that's been
true at every stage so you know about
now raise two rounds and I always try to
find people who you know because the
market is different raising a seriously
today is very different than a year ago
or two years ago so try to find people
have just done it and you try to learn
as many shorthand lessons as possible so
maybe shifting gears again I'm going to
talk about angels themselves and how
maybe all angels are not created equal
so we talked about value-added angels
and non-value-added angels is there a
difference between professional angels
so people that do this as a living
versus casual angels and I mean we can
talk a little bit about some of the VCS
that actually act like angels and and
and how that's impacting how companies
are getting funded so maybe I'll give
you the entrepreneurs viewpoints
and I just think that now more than ever
the whole angel investing model
especially for consumer internet makes a
lot of sense and I didn't have this
feeling in earlier companies that I did
but again if I haven't repeated it
enough times I absolutely do have that
feeling right now that it's a very
viable model and one should look at it
and I think VCS are sensing that as well
so they've either set aside funds or
they're willing to do smaller
investments or incubate you or do
entrepreneur in residence program
because I think the whole venture
economics have changed quite a bit in
the last few years with the change in
exits and the type of exits you can get
I think other than some funds they have
gotten smaller and more focused and so
you would expect to see those kind of
activities and I think the professional
angel is a lot more attractive than the
casual angel because the casual angel is
is really about money and the
professional angel is about value add
and with appropriate the appropriate
background and the appropriate context
so even though I've taken money from
casual angels before at this point I
would seriously look at professional
angels if I was doing the company yeah I
think again it's just to kind of give
you a practical answer majority of the
angels out there I've done a keynote on
this I think there are hundred thousand
angel investors in the US that's a
pretty broad definition right family and
friends are included in that so those
are people that have high conviction and
will probably give you money at any term
and then there are people that kind of
make three-four investments a year it's
kind of cool thing to do maybe there are
like great lawyers and doctors or other
professional services had some money
they kind of enjoy you know the thrill
of getting involved in a company I think
there are two key things you're looking
for here number one active right you
need to make sure that the person is
active is investing right now not in the
past right now what is their track
record are they actively investing
number two everything else being equal
the more investments or a more
comprehensive portfolio in angel has
more pattern recognition hands better
conviction easier conviction right and
it also gives you more data points of
how they made those decisions
probably see more trends in the
investment decisions they made if
somebody's already made to to investment
decisions over a course of five years
well draw your own conclusion versus
somebody that kind of has a
comprehensive portfolio and is very
active again you know those those are
all about probabilities of you know
connecting with the angel and then also
just be very clear I mean some angels
invest in smaller amounts some angels
and bigger amounts I think the other
distinction here is you know some people
have have huge wealth and they can
invest in huge amounts some of the
Angels have professional funds so they
can invest in comparable amounts and
some of the angels might invest in
smaller amounts yet add value in
different ways and just be clear who's
who and who do you need and you probably
might need some combination of those in
your syndicate and make sure that you
optimize for that but also be very clear
don't go after a hundred people that
invest at five K each don't also just go
after one person that's going to invest
a million because that's probably going
to move a little bit more difficult so
have a balance somewhere in the middle
I'll speak to the issue of venture funds
moving downstream into the angel market
because that's something I had a bit of
a bias about you know venture funds
typically have large large pools of
capital and and relatively few investing
partners and for them to be able to
invest to provide the kind of return
that their limited partners are
expecting they need to put a lot of
money to work and they need to have big
successes and that that structure does
not translate well into systemic angel
investing so to me it may seem appealing
to have you know a level brand name
venture firm investing in your seed
round alongside value-added angels and
value-added seed funds but it's
problematic it can it can be extremely
helpful it can be it can be a problem
particularly when you're trying to raise
your next round because you've sort of
God
you know the upside is you know you've
got brand a a level you know the
institutional VC firm they're you know
standing presumably ready to write a
check they know they're inside the tent
they know everything that's going on if
for any reason they choose not to invest
you might as well forget about it
exceptionally hard then to raise capital
to explain to another investor why you
know Joe here who's been backing you and
following you for 18 months it's decided
not to follow you so there are enough
sources of high-quality value-added
angel money today that I'd be reticent
to access institutional venture VC at
the scene room hey I was gonna head just
because I took some institutional angel
I sort of segment the angel investor
into four categories and this is what we
did at the time we were raising the
first is sort of institutional angels
and these are I wouldn't call the big
venture firms that have angel arms I
would call these are the venture firms
that basically focus on you know Ceres a
very early investing which we ended up
taking half of our series a from the
second would be professional angels the
third I call operational angels these
would be CEOs people know how to build
businesses from the early stage or
people who have operational excellence
in your category they don't necessarily
people that were at the senior level and
the fourth is just people with money and
when we were raising we took really a
hybrid of you know the people with money
the operational angels the professional
angels and we had this institutional
venture investor but I feel extremely
strongly that you want your lead if
possible to be a professional angel or
to be an institutional venture firm that
acts like an angel because when we went
to late Ray's later rounds they were
hugely important in representing the
entire angel group as a cohesive unit
and adding a lot of value to that
fundraising process and I got huge
advantage from operational Angels people
that were CEOs of companies or who had
built businesses in our category you
know if I were to do it all over again
today I would not take any money from
people who just had money but at the
time we didn't have that luxury but I
think that there you know for their very
early-stage VCS that can be very value
add but not the traditional firms that
just put small amounts in to dabble that
was our experience so you know it's
interesting because we always think of
investors due diligence on the
entrepreneurs and they come
what kind of due diligence should
entrepreneurs be doing on you as
investors and wouldn't have you guys you
both have done in terms of the due
diligence on your investors I'm sure so
initially when I first started out in my
first company I was a very keen to
involve a good venture capitalist in my
company and in my idea idea and to take
money from them and so I thought you
know with their help you know VC VC back
forums you know have a higher exit rate
or success rate that was my impression
and you know I didn't do too much to
diligence on them because I was just
keen to get them involved so I didn't
care if they were Dracula at night I
just I wanted their forms name into my
company because I thought that would
assure our success as a company of
course you know in subsequent rounds in
subsequent companies this change so I
actually either had a relationship with
them already
again I was introduced as a trusted
source I asked for other entrepreneurs
that they had worked with I checked some
of the blogs about what was being
written about them and and then the
third company you know not only did I
know you know want to know them and
their firms is on and so forth all that
level of due diligence but I also stayed
away from firms who just had a bad buzz
okay so I wouldn't even go to them even
though some reason so it was really keen
to meet you but some other entrepreneurs
had already told me that or you know
they had a bad experience or or the firm
had an experience of doing X and so even
if they had great cachet I just felt you
know the since I was doing this out of
choice now that I could choose and so
why would I even waste my time with them
and so those that had a bad buzz or
reputation you know I wouldn't even
bother to check their references I just
didn't want to
I didn't want to partner with them
really so I was just gonna add one other
simple things so I think this is also
kind of an expansion of our discussion
there's always this question of how much
money to take which firm to take from
and another important data point so when
you're approached
Vesey let's say the fund is 100 million
dollars so just to return the hundred
million dollars if they made five
investment decisions and all of them
were sold for hundred million dollars
and they own 20% of the company so
that's pretty much what they're gonna
shoot for right look at the font size
and that's pretty much the minimum exit
they're looking for and still they have
to get five of those just to return the
font needless to say the two to 3x exit
that they need to return to their LPS
right so that kind of gives you kind of
a spectrum of okay how much strings
we'll do VC attached or how much of my
company they're gonna want to have
because if it's a really large fund then
they're gonna want to have 30 40 percent
of your company because if the outcome
is big they need an even bigger number
so they're gonna want to own a bigger
percentage and the way I always like to
work with my entrepreneurs and my
founders is your job is to maximize the
probabilities of a successful outcome
right I don't know what that success is
that success could be a billion-dollar
IPO which is less and less likely these
days or it could be a you know fifty two
hundred million exit to a really good
company like Google and I've seen a lot
of those even in the deepest recession
and what I always tell people is I
cannot tell you what the right decision
is but what I can tell you is your job
is to maximize the likely outcomes and
choose between different outcomes right
never be cornered to only making one
decision that's the worst thing you can
do so your job is to basically optimize
for that and to do the homework for that
is really simple and like Bob said
that's one of the disadvantages of
venture firms and the reason why they're
getting so active in seed investing is
because the number of companies that
have the kind of traction and scale
they're looking for a lot fewer the
number of exits a lot fewer and angel
investors have kind of taken the early
lead what the venture capital firms once
used to be so they're feeling that if
they're not playing in our space they
cannot be competitive in the series bees
or Searcy so they're trying to be more
aggressive in that space I'd like to
reiterate something that I didn't said
earlier there are there's a wealth of
information readily available more so
every day about every investor the
prospective investor that you can meet
or hope to meet and you should be very
diligent about researching actively
before you meet people you know while
after you meet people due diligence on
them ask the prospective investor to
introduce you to people that they've
invested in before
good you know with good experiences and
bad experiences call them ask them ask
those entrepreneurs how they whether the
relationship with that prospective
investor was a positive one the more
diligence you do the the you reduce
dramatically the likelihood of any any
kind of negative result so I would just
add one thing I think that it's always
you know when times are good the
feedback you're gonna get is always
positive so it's important to ask for
those situations where things didn't
really turn out the way that either
party had hoped and how that was handled
because I think that that's gonna give
you a perspective on on how the investor
is gonna treat you when things go
sideways and you know things are not
marching according to plan because in a
startup there's lots of landmines in
front of you and there's always things
are always going to be off course it's
how you course-correct and whether you
do it at the same time and hand in hand
that makes a big difference
moment
money where the negotiations are the
same where the oil is like government
knows the same the terms were the same
for our all four groups in our deal
which was not it was not a convertible
but we just closed a series a but the
terms were for everyone we talked to in
that group look I mean like I said I
think it's a moving target you have to
be very careful I mean we're trying to
be helpful to you by giving some you
know milestones but don't take this as a
rule so a couple of quick things so
number one I think between convertible
and Series A I think anything that's
under a half a million could be quickly
closed and has the right incentives for
investors convertible notes are great
they don't provide enough incentives for
the sophisticated investors so the
moment you're going above 750 K to a
million I think a price round makes more
sense even though you know the voice
inside of you saying yes I would like to
have a convertible note like I said it's
a balance in general most VC firms want
to have at least 20% of the company you
know I don't think for angels that
number is all over the place but like
make sure that they have enough stake so
that they care about your company enough
and then what was the what was the other
question that we're talking about I
think he was saying what percentage of
the company do they really wanna own and
I think that pretty person I agree
you know like I said I give you just
look at the size of the fund the other
question you asked is how much money to
raise for it right and then again I'm
talking mostly for consumer Internet and
mobile if you're in consumer goods if
you're in retail if you're in life
sciences these are completely different
things you might have to raise a lot
more money if you're in semiconductor I
mean I don't know if you have a factory
or you're you know just the chip design
whatever it is but it used to be that 6
to 12 months was okay after the 2009 and
recession I think is still true there is
not enough liquidity out there even
though the stock market has decided you
know it started to pick up I would still
say conservatively 18 months is what you
should look for and there is always
again you know traditional rule of thumb
is whatever you think you're gonna do
it's probably gonna take twice as long
and you're gonna need twice as much
money
I don't know strike a happy balance
right things are never gonna go as
expected have a cushion don't run out of
money but don't raise too much money
that is gonna give you too much luxury
or you know too much relax you know you
have to be in some kind of a stressful
and aggressive time schedule here so you
have to make sure that everything is
lined up position where it is
frankly you've got PowerPoint username
entrepreneur nuts easiest way to get off
the ground is that what the Angels are
seeing you're going an outer sir that
your family it was kind of a small
series a or do you actually invest in
first-time entrepreneurs
yeah I'll respond to that one yes I do
invest in first-time entrepreneurs with
the PowerPoint
a lot depends really on on a you know
sort of a visceral feeling exiting a
first meeting about the person's ability
to succeed and then you know McCoy was
made earlier that you know the time
period necessary to get to a decision
depends in large part on a number of
variables but one really important one
is what's the entrepreneurs track record
first entrepreneur typically takes a
longer you know longer process time but
the fact that you're a first-time
entrepreneur does not is not a you know
a limiting factor for me in terms of
making a decision I think it also
depends on how hot your area is right so
I'm just gonna use an example I'm just
talking to the founder right now and I'm
just gonna say as I get build more and
more track record I'm probably leaning
more towards people that have some
traction or some Proofpoint
I mean it could be just a demo site
right I'm not looking for crazy things
unless something that is just a
PowerPoint slide but you know if your
area is difficult and it's gonna be hard
to convince people it's not one of those
hot areas you have to do whatever it
takes as an entrepreneur to get to the
first milestone that milestone could be
shipping the product it milestone could
be having some revenue being able to say
that is a very important thing if it
happens with family money great if Adams
with friends money great if it happens
with series a gray if happened with
convertible it doesn't matter what that
is the most important thing is to get to
that milestone and then improve your
chances of getting the funding to get to
the next milestone whatever it's gonna
take to get that traction moving the
side
the same without their resources and
finally to reduce background track
record ACO angel Angela goose the second
question I have is that under so many
questions as they'll be performing in
front of you to see what your masseur
challenges you obviously um so in order
to see who are the VCS and what they
track record is there's a website I
thing called venture source this is a
few of them that's one that you can look
at and that lists all the VCS and their
investments I think the funded may have
something as well some information on
companies and well this issue of
Businessweek that just came out is all
about angels in fact Ron Conway is on
the cover and items on that list okay
one of the top 20 I think he's number 13
in terms of is so everything about angel
so you can check that you know and this
do google it and it's a anyway said that
this issue of Business Week this week
it's all about angels now very excited
to see that so in terms of what problems
you face I mean I like that already you
guys yeah and I was gonna ask there is I
mean there are all these lists I mean
trust me but it's the same thing just
because I went to business school I
wasn't a different person and just
because I'm on a list I'm not like some
special angel or anything like that so
hopefully I can still keep helping
entrepreneurs there is also Forbes Midas
list again they're all these lists that
it gives you some information right just
because you're in a Midas list does that
make you a great VC I don't know but
it's some yardstick and you just look at
the investment decisions they made like
I said I think more important than the
investors name or a firm's name is the
partner who you're going to work with
and you know your chances of creating
the positive bias towards your idea my
biggest challenge as an investor is I'm
an entrepreneur like yourself I don't
have anybody helping me I don't have any
admin I'm always missing out on things I
can't follow up on every lead and for
instance I don't have a very good rating
on funder this is because I can't
respond to every entrepreneur a lot of
times I can't even explain why I can't
get to someone because I don't have time
and that's probably my biggest challenge
because the
only way I can be successful is
optimizing which bets I make because I
have to make those bets count and like I
said I'm getting 10 to 15 leads there's
no way I'm gonna be able to get all of
them every day and that's that's my
biggest challenge but my hope is that by
supporting the right entrepreneurs and
creating success they're like one of the
coolest things about being on that list
they actually listed how many jobs were
created by the companies I backed and
how much money was raised so I'm like
wow like not only was i lucky at Google
but I was able to back companies that
created new businesses and created new
jobs so there's some satisfaction of
seeing that but anyway Bob yeah my
biggest challenge is just not having
enough time in the day to meet to meet
with everybody who wants to meet with me
I like like I don't have a an admin or
much infrastructure and I'm my record is
spotty at best at making meetings and
and returning calls just gives the list
of things that I have to do is you know
a mile long every day like an
entrepreneur so it's about optimizing
and and you know trying to direct my
efforts to where they'll produce the the
the best result and a lot of times I you
know means I I don't do everything that
everybody expects me to do
they follow and they're mostly above
regardless of the value I tried
so we hang out at least in those offices
in software and it's useful this is a
good way to get beautiful environment so
you can also get creative so one of the
best advice that I heard when I was
starting angel investing as a VC friend
of mine told me that if you want to make
sure that the product that you're
investing is not bad try doing a Google
search with the product or company name
and then sucks
because I mean you'd be blown away just
try this for anything you'd be blown
away how much information you can get by
just doing this simple thing then create
some iteration right I mean Google my
name and just say oh he's an awful guy
whatever I mean I have no idea what
people are saying about me and then you
can meet me and kind of balance the two
right like maybe I'm like that maybe I'm
not I don't know but again it doesn't
really take rocket science to find out
information about someone to LinkedIn
through their track record through these
lists and everything else the only I was
gonna add is if you're an entrepreneur
and you go to your board meeting and you
say that you know you're not getting
back to everyone because you don't have
an assistant the first thing your
investors say well we go get an
assistant so maybe
I sent an intern opportunity to an early
stage traction I don't know about any
interest of a potential value tonight
oh one quick thing I want to highlight
here be very careful when you're doing
the advisory board the thing that you
have to watch out is I love your company
I don't want to risk the chance of
investing my own money but I can be
advisor for a percentage of the company
or angel groups that charge you to
present I mean those kind of things I
think is like a ruckus but on the other
hand an advisory board is really
important in the sense that especially
if you're a cheap company or life
sciences and your risk are a lot higher
and you have to overcome really high
odds an advisory board can be extremely
helpful in convincing your investors
that when you do hit those rough
milestones and you need to execute on it
your advisors can help you open some of
those doors they could be people that
can help you generate sales they could
be people that can call FDA I don't know
who they are but be very very clear that
they have a clear value add and not just
names to add on the Advisory list
because there will be people are like oh
I can't really invest but I would love
to be your advisor for 5% of your
company so you know you have to make
that decision you know I thought the big
challenge from an entrepreneurs
perspective of an advisory board is
actually making use of that advisory
board so I've many times had lots of
people ready to be advisors and given
them you know some token amount of
shares to keep their interest and then
never had time to really have an
advisory board meeting or have one
that's at all useful or have and then
they get busy right and then all of a
sudden you know two years are over they
earned their shares and you never talk
to them and they never did anything for
you and the problem is with putting
people on advisory boards it is really
difficult to get them off because in
then then
then the exact insulting like you never
called me you never had time for me you
didn't ask me for my advice and now you
want to throw me out like you can
actually ruin a great relationship if
you don't handle it correctly so over
the years I've experimented with the
advisory board structure and I think the
best advice advisory boards are for me
what worked was really small like two or
three people do you have time to talk to
them and then I made it so it wasn't
tied to a meeting it was tied to sort of
quarterly action items or quarterly
meetings with me so you would get chairs
but they vest
you know the vest when you meet with me
so we have to have a meeting and it was
surprising how many advisory board
members called me today we haven't met
this month what do you need so second
you know five thousand shares but we
have to have this meeting so you really
have to spend time in organizing that
program and then making use of it and
when advisory boards don't work it's
because of us
the entrepreneurs because you know you
can see the person you can see that
they're interested you can figure out
what's right to give them so why isn't
it working
why is it a waste of your shares because
you didn't have time to tap into them
properly so I would keep that in mind so
two more things real quick I don't have
two founders and ten advisers right I
mean you also want to build a team if
people don't want to work with you but
still wanna kinda have the option of
benefiting from the company's success
that's another important thing and the
law and again your advisers are not a
substitute for your ability to execute
so don't just think that having ten
incredible advisor names is gonna get
you over the hurdle of like convincing
the investors that you can deliver but I
know actually is absolutely right that a
small number again be very clear what
specific value they're adding and make
sure that the incentives are aligned so
like tie it to the actual meetings or
sometimes actual deliverables who cares
about two years it could be two hours
you make the call you get me this deal
you get shares it's as simple as that so
the only thing I was gonna add to that
is what I've noticed because we've had
advisors is a different stage in the
company that one of the mistakes we made
when we started the company was we had a
small number of shares since
for an advisor you know they might get a
thousand shares which seemed like
nothing but later in the company's
history we did a split people had more
shares and many times it's just it seems
like they have a larger number even
though the value is no different and so
when I look back had we had more shares
I probably could have given up less of
the company which would have been a more
appropriate given the amount of value we
gave so I just always tell people it's
better to have more shares in the
beginning this most people don't ask
that are good like for example if you're
going to go into a sales cycle to an
enterprise or you're going to go into a
sales cycle to a drug company or
something like that and you have you
know the X you know some big regulatory
muckety-muck or Colin Powell or somebody
then you know it's great to have them on
the website don't expect to ever talk to
them but you know it'll make your sales
app a little bit easier and maybe
there'll be a couple of calls so this M
cached having those names that help you
with your specific vertical as well
I would love Bob to chime in here too
but I think the ideal scenario and some
CEOs and founders do this really well
like Todd they give you quarterly
updates I think that's kind of the
minimum amount of time you need to be
able to show traction even though some
of my companies can iterate as fast as
every two weeks I think it has to be
reasonable of time and just some update
I mean I don't need to every know
everything that's happening in the
business I want to know you're not
running out of money
hopefully you're fighting for leadership
hopefully you're executing and you know
the company is growing both in terms of
revenues traction or some other metric
and you're hiring the right people right
it's not that that complicated I think
the important thing here is not to mix
like if I have to call the entrepreneur
to get information out then I made the
wrong decision right I think it's only
the respectful thing to do and it
doesn't have to be formatted just send
me a half page email saying here's the
updates and by the way here are two
things I need help with can you you know
can any of you guys and it doesn't it
could be just go to all the investors so
it's great like now I know the company
is doing okay and I know two specific
things that I can be of help why would I
need to have to call you every week to
find out how you're doing number one and
two to justify my existence as an
investor or board member you normally
see that when people only make two
investments a year and they have to
justify I only have two investments per
year because I have to spend a lot of
time with them I'm like it doesn't
matter you know are you making any
difference for them or not from an
entrepreneur perspective I think you
want your your investors to be investors
not managing your company and so you
know you know I have I've dealt with
both types I have had investors who talk
to you every day which is very very
annoying and the others that are not
available enough and you really need
them and you need their help so it's
really important to set up you know the
right level of communication so
basically I don't like my investors to
be surprised and I know that in order to
make full use of them I have to I have
to ask and so if I don't keep them up
today how they're traveling around they
might see a business deal
they won't even recognize that it's a
good deal for me because I forgot to
tell them that I'm having these three
incredible sales
cycles and incredible results with some
implementation that I just did right so
you have to strike the right balance
there one of the things that I do a
practical point is is early on after
making an investment I agree with the
entrepreneur what the the KPIs are for
the business and I encourage the
entrepreneur to you know every week
every couple of weeks publish something
it can be as simple as a Google Doc or
Google spreadsheet that outlines result
you know performance over the past
whatever the relevant time horizon is
it's an easy way for the entrepreneur to
do it on his own his or her own time for
me to view it on my own time without
interfering with the entrepreneur and
for issues to be to be identified and
addressed you know relatively promptly
and I'm just gonna add one other thing
on Bob the reason why I like consumer
Internet and mobile at this point is
very important how do you define success
of a business on the Internet is very
simple do you have users are they
growing are you making money of them and
you can measure it very quickly that's
one of the reasons I like it because I
can actually see if it's working and if
it's not working we can fix it in a
traditional business say like I was in
textiles I have to order the textiles it
has to be manufactured it has to come it
has to go to the store by the time I
know that I failed it's been six months
and it's too late to change the train so
again for every business there are
different metrics and there are
different criteria but you know just
wanted to add that
[Music]
[Music]
bitching
I could chime in you know on the have I
ever done it so as an entrepreneur
you'll be approached by a lot of these
trade events you know to pay to pitch so
it's like a participation via stack a
trade show right or you know will
it's a sixteen thousand dollar
production fee and you can be on all the
you know programs on American Airlines
okay
I've never done those I've actually
never pitched at any of those events and
you know the minute I say what is a
production via I'm not ok well great
this is when you think I'm newsworthy
I'll do it so but I've actually been a
judge and attended demo and I find great
startups over there right so you know I
mean it's really up to you know if you
if you have a targeted group of people
that you want to meet I don't think that
these trade shows in particular aren't
bad venues because you do have certain
number of angels and VCs walking around
and you you I love to attend them
because I see good you know great things
and it's it's a great way to find out
what's new and you definitely meet a lot
of feces and and the angels that are
walking around trying to see what's new
so it just depends on if you want this
huge exposure or you have a targeted
list that you're going after anyway and
what the cash flow situation is yeah I
was just gonna add my father is actually
a member of the karatsu forum which is
one angel group set that charges and I'd
personally didn't go and pay the fee and
pitch to it and I think that there's a
lot of other options than paying to
pitch to raise money and I think that if
if it can be avoided I would definitely
recommend it in terms of the big
Marketing conferences I think there's
there's a lot of success that's come out
of TechCrunch 50 and similarly with demo
you know for us I've just seen so many
companies pour a lot of capital into
these events you know conferences and
things like that I think like a
marketing launch like a one-time thing
makes some sense and for us there's a
specific set of conferences which are
you know there's a hundred and fifty
people that we sit in a room and give a
half-an-hour presentation to who are the
exact buyers that buy our products so
for that for us that makes sense but
almost nothing else has so I just you
know I just booth lessly manage that
that twenty grand and you have you
pretty damn sure it's money well-spent
to spend it I think I think Tata Nano
are absolutely right it has to be for a
very specific reason these days the only
events I go to and I might pay a high
price for is to basically have a hundred
meetings all at once right so Todd said
50 investors you can go to one of these
events and feel like you can meet 40 of
them then it's a good investment but
don't go to these events I don't think
any of us would make an investment
because a company was selected into one
of these events and like one of the top
ten finalists whatever I mean it's nice
to have but I don't think that solely
justifies the decision the biggest
important for you thing for you is
networking
I mean networking for sales networking
to raise money if any one of these
events would facilitate it and has very
high quality people I have to underscore
three times high quality people not just
you know people that you're gonna run
into that's then that definitely you
have to make that call but then it's
worth painful
[Music]
today's company's getting equity into
the hands of key employees before the
angel Rena red Sun no options warrants
spot grants and you know what your
preferences and also how do you think
about the pricing of those different
options if they're you know I'll take
that one I think in in most cases
empirically founders and and employees
on board prior to my investment are
compensated by you know restricted stock
purchases so they actually purchased the
stock with a buyback buyback a company
buyback right and it's subject to
vesting and so on yeah one of the things
that that angels you know more
sophisticated angels or more funds do is
you impose the same sort of controls on
a company that a VC might so try to work
out the issues of founder vesting and so
forth in a way that will make the
company unobjectionable for a for a
downstream investor pricing typically is
is you know sent you know you know as
close to zero as possible at the very
early stage and that and there's not a
whole lot of objection around that I
don't think a couple things are out so
mostly after the investment is a 409a
process and you have to do it with
professional evaluators it's important
to have balance in terms of you know one
founder having eighty percent and then
everybody else having point zero one I
mean you kind of want balance you want
key employees to be incentive and you
want there to be sufficiently large
option pool for new key employees again
it depends if you have two people ten
people who do you need to hire to kind
of round out the team and that it's
balanced and the people have the right
incentives important part of the point
important part of the pricing discussion
in in any priced round is the size of
the pool you know there are three
elements to to venture valuation it's
you know the valuation
the size of the pool and founders stay
and that's you know their rules of thumb
about how should be but ultimately
that's that's a negotiated I have
filters you know I natural filters that
we've talked about before entrepreneurs
that I've worked with lawyers is because
of my background is a good filter for me
virtually every startup company you know
goes to a mini go to a lawyer before
they look for capital so I see a lot of
deals referred in from lawyers other
investors in my network with whom I've
invested previously a Series A or
institutional venture firms who see
deals that they think aren't exactly
ripe for an investment by them will send
stuff down so but but you know for me
the the you know if it doesn't if
there's not a referral from a trusted
source the likelihood that I'll see it
is is diminished greatly
for me it's it you know it depends on
the sector that the company's an and the
amount being raised but but generally
it's a hundred to two hundred fifty
thousand initial investment and then
reserve some to continue to participate
and its twenty five two hundred fifty
for me with you know most of the
investments being somewhere in the
middle and coming back to the earlier
question how do you mean an investor you
know what B is creative as you can if
somebody is a big biker instead of
schedule a meeting say hey can we go for
a bike ride you know I mean just be
different right so if everybody is
asking for a coffee meeting you should
be asking for the bike ride if the
person is a big golfer hey you know I
happen to be a good golfer - can we like
talk you know just make the discussion
as pleasurable as possible and don't
make it like hey I'm going to the
dentist oh my god like this person is
desperate to get the funds they haven't
done their homework to the die you know
like just go through the checklist and
you know make the meeting you know
increase your likelihood of getting that
meeting find the right connections you
know think out of the box I invited ITIN
the coffee and still works well he
invited me to coffee in my previous shop
in San Francisco I buy all my magazines
so that definitely works so we're
actually out of time right we don't have
one more quick question hopefully yeah
[Music]
let's just say is save and soft like
this and another software the company
comes and eats
so I think look these days is happening
more and more I mean I'm just being
amazed at how many times like I'll see a
company and within three weeks there are
like seven other companies that are in
the same space to the extent that I can
I try not to invest in any one of them
because I feel that if there are six
seven one of them they're gonna all kill
each other's business
I'll price them and you know hire each
other's Talent in some cases I can't
help it I mean there is a situation
where you know I invested in three
companies one of them was Todd's company
and they started in all different places
and within a year and a half ended up in
the right place I can't control that and
I'm also very upfront and tell the
entrepreneurs I can't sign an NDA only
tell me whatever you need to tell me
that's necessary for me to get a
reasonable idea I mean exercise good
judgment obviously if I do something
that's really bad I'm not gonna be in
business I'm never gonna do that but
also I can't really help like hearing
things right I mean you you'll see
things that that happen it almost
happens too quickly sometimes you hear
without even people intending to pitch
you so unfortunately it's the nature of
our business and things are moving
really small like I said exercise good
judgment and and I try to be very
upfront and transparent and I say look I
have these companies in my portfolio or
I've seen this in this so I try to be
upfront in terms of explaining my
circumstances to people so they can make
the best decision for themselves for
guys like us who are you know have are
profound you know semi-professional
whatever have to have websites and so
forth it's a lot easier for you to do
diligence and figure out whether at
least reduce the probability that
there's going to be a conflict of
interest my policy is if somebody sends
me you know an executive summary that's
clearly in conflict with the company
that that I've already invested in I'll
tell I'll say you know take a look at
this company you know if you think that
that's you know my investment
involvement in that company is a problem
for you
you know then don't call me back if you
still want to meet I'd be interested to
meet but you have to be aware that you
know even the most scrupulous honorable
people you know are going to you know
information is going to get shared in in
some way
that may or may not be the productive
for you you know there are VCS and
angels that have this information on
their website and others don't and I've
actually had experiences where a VC is
looking at to emerging deals including
one was mine and they've been incubating
the competitor in in their own office
space and they didn't tell us about it
and they actually asked us that meeting
after meeting like oh well okay let's
hit three meetings what are you finding
out is this a valid space who did you
which customer did you talk to and then
there's a meeting when they said could
you lay out your product vision for the
next two years on the board and actually
got up to write it and then something
was the creepy so I said you know let's
not go there you know I you know I've
got term sheets coming up and I ended
the meeting
so you've meet all kinds of people and
what what is it's up to you what I've
learned is that you just have to be very
careful how much of your kimono you're
willing to open okay
yeah so uh now you just have to just say
enough but not everything ever so on
that note I hope you'll join me in
thanking